[Music]
there is yet more evidence that you
really can't go home
even if that's where your dreamy eyed
mom lives as it looks like we won't be
going back to back to the future anytime
soon and while we've certainly heard as
much from christopher lloyd michael j
fox and director robert zemeckis the
news comes from two beloved supporting
actors claudia wells and james tolkin
wells who played marty's girlfriend
jennifer in the first back to the future
before being replaced by elizabeth schuh
and tolkien who betrayed high school
principal mr strickland were interviewed
in a virtual panel on september 20th
2020 when the inevitable moment came and
the pair were asked about the chances of
a new franchise entry they had their
answers locked in like einstein in the
front seat of the delorean
no we've done it it's it's done one two
and three
please that we're we're quite happy with
that
the og jennifer added that the trilogy
screenwriter has been consistent with
his answer saying
bob gale's always been very adamant
about there is no back to the future for
wells also shared a story about
christopher lloyd telling the creator of
brokeback to the future
a satirical viral trailer edit from 2006
that added some brokeback mountain style
romance to the original back to the
future film
that his remix was as close to a fourth
film as we're ever going to get
chris looked at him and goes that's back
to the future for because it's not going
to happen otherwise
everyone says no tolkien and wells are
just two more voices in a seemingly
endless course of folks involved with
the original trilogy
screaming into an unbillable void to fan
expectations that no
there are no plans for another back to
the future movie bob gale who co-wrote
back to the future in both of its
sequels put the decision into firmly
worded focus earlier this year
speaking to the bbc with the verven
focus of a man who's been asked the same
question over and over again for 30
years he said
we already made a lot of money you know
you don't sell your kids into
prostitution
it was the wrong thing to do we put the
end at the end of part three
plus michael j fox isn't in the shape to
do a movie and nobody wants to see marty
mcfly having parkinson's disease
and nobody wants to see another actor
playing marty mclive it's supposed to be
a continuation
we've already seen the star wars movies
and luke skywalker is an old man
that can be a little bit painful right
robert zemeckis meanwhile has been
nothing if not clear about the odds of
another back to the future sequel
stating at different points that it
would be hubris to try to add to the
story and that a remake would be
outrageous
he told the telegraph in 2015 it's like
saying let's remake citizen kane
who are we going to get to play kane
what folly what insanity is that
why would anyone do that in case his
point wasn't clear he told bad taste in
2018
there will never ever be in the most
absolute way a back to the future 4
there will be no more back to the future
as icing on the cake tom wilson who
played biff in all three of the original
movies went so far as to write a comedy
song about how back to the future part 4
is never ever going to happen it can't
make it much more clearer than that
so we have back to the future parts one
through three but what if that isn't
enough
what if 343 minutes of time traveling
antics just doesn't hit the spot
luckily fans of the series in need of a
fresh hit can always turn to that old
reliable source of nostalgia feels
the extended universe at the basic end
of the spectrum there's the noblest of
90s cash grabs the saturday morning
cartoon
from september of 1991 to december of
the following year a back to the future
animated series ran for 26 episodes on
the cbs network
characterized by bob gale as
non-canonical what-if universe
adventures it explored marty and doc's
family-friendly escapades through
history
fun fact it's the first national tv
series to feature acclaimed science guy
bill nye
starring an educational live-action
segments at the end of each episode
additionally for the discerning
collector gale co-wrote an official
sequel series to the movies published in
comic book form in 2015.
initially published as back to the
future untold tales and alternate
timelines the series was pretty much
exactly what the title implies
a collection of sequel stories taking
place after the events in the movies as
well as possible scenarios from parallel
realities
and at video games or more your speed
telltale games released an episodic
adventure in 2010 which even featured
voices of christopher
lloyd and a couple of cameos michael j
fox in short there's still plenty of
future to go back to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one